[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and
i'm solo today
i just got off the phone with ryan and
well
he has a children's cold he did lose his
sense of taste and smell
but
he's tested negative for covid five
times in the last week or so and so he
has a cold a bad cold i don't want to
get anyone sick here but don't worry
we have
a studio full of people who have
microphones as well i'll be asking them
to butt in from time to time we have
jordan no more we have podcast shawn we
have danny unknown and of course we have
alabama here she's reading your
questions
now we all know how troublesome material
clutter can be
but what about paper clutter bills mail
receipts taxes photos books pamphlets
files contracts letters and other random
paperwork today on the public podcast
we're talking about one of the most
requested topics we ever get paper
clutter
then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast we're going to talk
about other types of clutter career
clutter emotional clutter calendar
clutter and much more clutter you can
find that long form conversation at
patreon.com
the minimalists you'll also gain
immediate access to hundreds of hours of
private archives your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me
advertisements
suck
yes they do
our first question today is from susan
on facebook
paper clutter is a big problem for me
what important documents do we really
need to keep and what can be tossed into
a dumpster fire
susan there's some obvious discontent
here like the i don't recommend a
dumpster fire i don't even recommend a
dumpster for paper you can certainly
recycle it but i appreciate the
sentiment because i get it it is
frustrating to have to deal with sort
through all of this paper clutter so
first we have to start by talking about
what is
clutter
not just with paper but in our lives
what is clutter well clutter means we
have excess of something that also gets
in the way so if you have excess papers
that are getting in the way now they may
get in the way physically but not always
they also might get in the way and i
think this is even more important more
troublesome and this is why it's a big
problem for you susan
i think the reason that it gets in the
way as it gets in the way emotionally
and mentally it creates new clutter for
us
it sort of weighs in the back of our
mind like oh i really should scan that i
really should do something about my file
cabinet or cabinets i really should do
something about all this excess mail
that i get what about my taxes what
about all these photos i've been meaning
to scan and all these things i keep
getting these stacks and stacks of mail
and i'm just sort of letting it sit
there for a while what about all of
these files and accordion files and
manila envelopes and folders and oh yeah
i signed this contract back in 2006. do
i need to hold on to that
what we're hearing here that voice in
our head that is saying all these things
to us that is a type of clutter that is
mental clutter and so
you're asking me what important
documents do we really need to keep and
what can be tossed into
a dumpster fire or what can you recycle
what what can you get rid of and
the answer is there are only a few
things that i
find to be absolutely essential to keep
so that's like a social security card
birth certificates
there can be a few documents that you
may want a physical copy of but even
those like taxes for example i just
talked to my accountant before we
started recording this episode and
all of our tax documents now are all
backed up online and in the cloud so
i think one of the greatest problems
about paper clutter is also the fact
that if you were to lose it if you had a
house fire or a dumpster fire that
caught your house on fire that's
actually a story from our last book love
people use things
if that were to happen you might
actually lose all the paperwork so that
creates more worry more anxiety in your
life and that's obviously not what you
want susan and so
the things that you might need even then
the social security card the birth
certificates you still want some sort of
digital backup of those in case
something were to happen to them i know
a few years ago
well this is a while ago now but i used
to keep my social security card in
my glove box stupidly and i say stupidly
because it got stolen someone broke into
my car and i only had a few things in
in my car and in the glove box literally
i had my social security card i had
my registration to my vehicle which is
another piece of paper that i have
that i need whenever i'm on you know
driving somewhere also my insurance we
have a little insurance card there as
well in california you have to have the
physical card other states you can make
do with simply a digital card and so the
question isn't what documents do i need
but what documents can i digitize and
the answer is most of them you can
digitize
and however you actually don't even need
most of the things you might consider
digitizing in the future in fact going
through the process of digitizing we're
going to talk about that today what are
some of the best methods to do that some
of the best techniques for that because
this is a fairly mechanical thing and so
i can get prescriptive on this episode i
can give you some how to's if you're
unsure of where to go but before that it
really starts with the why too
understanding
why simplifying the paper clutter is
going to be beneficial to you
because it might
relieve or even alleviate some of that
anxiety or all of the anxiety you're
feeling around the excess that is
accumulating the excess paper that's
accumulating in your home
alabama looks like we have a question
here from kim on patreon what companies
do you recommend to have your photos
saved to the cloud i want to do this but
am worried about sending my photos off
yeah so you can send your photos off in
fact there are a few places you can send
them to there's no advertisements on
this podcast obviously no sponsors no
recommendations but i can tell you of
some different services the one that i
know that has the best reviews is a
website called scan my photos it's just
scan myphotos.com we'll put a link to
that in the show notes now what to scan
my photos do if you want to send them
off somewhere and they can handle them
for you now you can take care of it
yourself and we'll talk about that in a
moment but if you want to send your
photos off
you can send off your photos also old
slides if you have old movie slides or
just old old photo slides old negatives
of photos you actually physical photos
or film photos that you you took if you
have negatives you can send those to
to them as well
but also vhs's
eight millimeter film online storage for
all of those things so you can have them
backed up they can store them for you
for a fee obviously and then also they
can provide you with
a usb drive or even a dvd i don't know
who would use that but some people have
dvd drives they can provide you with
that so you don't have to just use
scan my photos or other companies like
scan digital ever present
cafe
go photo
digital memories these are different
companies that essentially do
very similar services now there's also
another company that a lot of our
listeners have recommended to me
and it's called one dollar scan it's
just one dollarscan.com we'll put a link
to that in the show notes as well so a
lot of people have book clutter in fact
i rarely have ever done any um solo
episodes of the minimalist podcast i did
one intentionally because
it was about writing
early early on i think it was way back
like episode 16 or something and then i
did an episode about book clutter let's
put a link to that episode in the show
notes sean i really enjoyed that
jordan and sean were there but it was
the only other solo episode that i can
recall and
in there we talked about booklet getting
rid of the excess books that might be
getting in the way and i was the prime
example of this i had 2 000 books in my
life many of which i hadn't read but
held on to them because i thought they
made me look smart or impressive or you
know some nonsense like that but there
were some books where i'm like i do
definitely want to read this one or
maybe i'll read this someday or here's a
textbook i want to reference at some
point but i don't want to take it up
space in my house and there you can use
onedollarscan.com
basically you send them
your books and they can turn them into
color pdfs for you and then they recycle
the books they work with international
paper to recycle the books for you and
it's real simple you basically just you
order and and you can send off your your
books and then what they do is they cut
the spine they scan and digitize your
books
and then they send you the files that
you need so you don't have to worry
about that book clutter you don't have
to worry about recycling them because
man it's a real pain to try to
try to well bring stacks and stacks and
stacks of books although if you do have
access books certainly bring them to
your local library you know i always
encourage people whenever they buy one
of our books like love people use things
or everything that remains when you're
done with it minimize the book and you
can do so at your local library that way
someone else can get value from it as
opposed to just collecting
dust on your shelf and so
yeah you can use these services or
you can do it on your own you can have
what we call a photo scanning party or
you can even do this with documents as
well you could do a document scanning
party in fact if you go to
theminimalists.com
scanning you can read about the photo
scanning part you can see the scanner
that ryan and i use in our own home so
that's why i'm not recommending these
services necessarily i haven't used one
dollar scan myself i have not used
scanmyphotos.com myself although i've
had tons of listeners recommend both of
those services and i've looked into them
they seem relatively reputable and the
the feedback on those has been
tremendous however
as a do-it-yourself kind of guy ryan and
i just we have a digital scanner that
will scan documents it'll scan photos
that are i think up to you know full
paper size here right here's some irony
i have a little paper during our paper
clutter episode
but i'm doing most of this from my
computer because there's another type of
clutter in our lives that i find
sometimes it's better to have paper when
ryan and i are here together we never
put screens between us but why because
there's screen clutter and that's much
more pernicious for a relationship with
someone than having some paper that is
set between us so i do have a few show
notes here but most of my stuff today
because i'm not sitting across from ryan
most of the stuff i have today is just
digital right here on my computer so kim
yes there are some services you can use
you can also do a photo scanning party
yourself now why is it called a photo
scanning party it's because
well if you are scanning your documents
that's kind of boring right scanning
photos oh
who wants to have to do this well you
can make it a bit more fun if you put
the word party at the end of anything it
instantly becomes more fun but you can
actually turn it into a party how do you
do that let's say you have several boxes
of photos in your garage or your attic
or in your closet and they're just
sitting there now if anything happens to
your house what let's say you're you get
you get robbed
the house burns down there's a flood or
or a fire in the closet whatever it
might be you might lose all of those
photos right
and so
if you back them up you don't lose
the photos
and so if you have a scanning party you
just grab all those photos you make a
day out of it so you know next saturday
i'm going to bring some friends over
some family members over and we're going
to do this together in fact if i do this
at my house this weekend we'll do this
at your house next weekend so one or two
friends and if you do that all of a
sudden it makes the experience more
meaningful for a couple reasons one is
you start pulling out these photos
instead of just cramming them into your
scanner
you talk about oh my gosh i can't
can't believe it's been 20 years since
we went to this amusement park together
it's been 15 years since we went to
hawaii wouldn't it be awesome if we went
back there look at this picture of me
surfing wow and so you're you're having
these conversations sparking
conversations as opposed to them just
collecting dust over there in a closet
in addition to that you can see the
digital picture frame that i use and
that ryan uses same same link there the
minimalists.com scanning
here's the thing after you're done
scanning these photos
you can actually use them in a digital
picture frame and those digital picture
frames tend to be much more appealing
much more magnetic
than
if you were just to put a regular
picture frame up i'm not sure why that
is maybe it's just that we're so drawn
to
glowing screens and it rotates through
your top 50 photos or 100 photos or
thousand photos or whatever you want to
rotate through on that digital picture
screen and you can also upload new
photos to it via wi-fi
oh and so you're always
preserving those memory triggers i say
memory triggers because the memories
aren't actually in the photos but they
can trigger the memories that are inside
you and then you can decide you know
what i'm going to let go of the physical
photos if they're getting in the way or
if you want to hold on to some of them
great but as you go through the scanning
party here's what you're really going to
learn
i don't remember most of these photos
who the heck is this in this photo why
is there just a photo of my thumb next
to this dog
i have no idea why do i have 14 of the
same picture here i don't need all of
this excess and so having your own
scanning party allows you to eliminate
the excess to get it into the cloud so
you can store it digitally now there are
a few services that you can use
in fact if you want to back up your your
photos you can use like box or dropbox
is what we use here at the minimalists
uh google drive is another one idrive is
a popular service so we'll put links to
those in the show notes as well if
you're wanting to back up your photos in
the cloud with me
i have two backups i have a redundancy
they are on my hard drive
separate from my computer
and then they're also in the cloud now
it's up to you if you want to
keep some of those physical photos as
well you can find a nice way to organize
them maybe you want to put them in a
photo album and then that will give you
some creative limitations you know what
this photo album only fits 500 photos
well those that's how many photos i'm
going to keep and anytime i want to keep
a new one i might have to get rid of one
of these and that way i'm not hoarding
excess photos but then i have the
physical
the physical
memory trigger there for me and it's so
much better either way whether it's
digitized and in the digital picture
frame or you have the photo album there
than if you would just have them in a
box somewhere in a house or a storage
locker and it's long forgotten
we have another question here from kat
on patreon actually josh can i interrupt
for just one second yeah on this
um
i
uh notice that some people um
are like hey i'm gonna wait till i get a
scanner or i'm gonna wait to the get the
perfect tool right yes
um
honestly most people have the perfect or
near perfect tool in their pockets with
a smartphone i've taken pictures of
pictures
countless pictures uh and even in like
google drive or google photos right yes
the automatic settings in there to kind
of tweak photos is really pretty good
yeah absolutely and the camera's on
these phones now
are even even the least expensive phones
are still about as good as a really good
scanner so as long as you have some
decent lighting yes you know where
you're taking the picture of the picture
or the document
right because they have some um pdf like
free pdf apps and stuff although i don't
think you really need it unless you
really want to build a pdf well let me
let me let me add on to that real quick
so apple now
in the apple notes app which is what i
use for organizing now has a native
scanning function so you can actually
use your iphone to scan i use this i
don't use it for photos necessarily but
i use it for documents all the time if
we need to send something to our
accountant
scan it right away and then shred it no
longer am i dealing with that paper
clutter but you bring up a great point
you don't need the perfect tool you
don't have to wait for the perfect time
this weekend is the perfect time to get
started yeah you need to take action and
get it rolling you can get the perfect
scanner another time if if that's your
thing
but honestly yeah i've i've used my
phone
uh for all the for stuff here right yeah
for a lot of our documents i'll just
take a picture of it and and save that
and and it's perfect so
yeah thank you podcast sean
cat has a question for us
what have you found are the most
effective methods for organizing
important paper documents in the office
a shredder
yes i second that so we do have a
shredder here and it was a we bought a
pretty high quality one now if you don't
have to have
a bunch of documents shred
sometimes banks will actually allow you
to shred documents at the bank in fact
we uh we just got a call on episode 319
someone called in and left a minimalism
tip for us you can leave us your tips as
well 406 219-7839
or email a voice memo to podcast the
minimalists dot com
and we'll include your minimalism tips
in a future episode and this person
called in from santa barbara and said
hey my bank actually because i am a
customer there my bank allows me
to keep my
my um
social security card my birth
certificate and any other important
documents i need in a safety deposit box
at no additional charge now some banks
may actually charge you for a safety
deposit box but if you're worried about
having your documents on site
excuse me and then what she also did was
have copies of those and as she replaced
her whole file cabinet with just one
small accordion file and so she had
copies of those and she put her key to
the to the box in that accordion file so
she ever needs to access those but then
she also has them backed up digitally as
well i think the digital redundancy is
really important because when we lose
those things it's hard to even prove
that i had a driver's license or a
passport or whatever else but having
photos of those things or having them
scanned allows you to replace them much
more easily so back to what do we do
in a business setting
well
we scan
as much as we need to
most things instantly get shredded
and we're going to talk in a moment
about well how do we prevent new
paper clutter from coming in to our
office into our homes because that's
really the biggest problem once we've
dealt with our paper clutter that exists
now well we all of a sudden start
getting more and more and more and it's
piles up in our mailbox which should
really just be called a junk box
at this point i mean who is still
sending mail these days very rarely
although the irony is as the minimalists
we get
really great letters from
anyone who listens to the podcast or
reads the website and in fact we prefer
snail mail here because we've sort of
taken it back uh it's better than email
it's much more intentional if we're
using it that way but really what's
happening in our homes is
marketers advertisers major
multinational corporations are buying
and selling our information so they can
try to sell us products
that we don't even need
in the first place so cat what is the
most effective method for organizing and
paper organizing paper documents i think
the truth is i don't know that we have
any paper documents here alabama we
don't have a file cabinet here do we do
not yeah and so
we don't have a file cabinet here we
don't have anywhere we store paperwork
although we
podcast sean you you scan and store
things and contracts all the time
but we don't have a physical copy of
those and we're not worried about it for
one second
no
yeah no digital works digital works
perfectly fine for everybody today
legally
let's move on to our callers if you have
a question or comment 406
219-7839 emily in seattle washington has
a question for us growing up i came from
a family where paper clutter was normal
it was encouraged my mother kept every
single piece of paper from every single
grade every meaningless assignment and
that was really challenging as an adult
to get married and move out and realize
i had those habits as well
so what are some of your favorite
resources to help me stop paper clutter
from even coming through my front door
i think it's important to recognize that
times change and
emily you've recognized that you know
what the time has changed it used to be
that the only way we could receive
communications from people was paper
clutter showing up in fact it wasn't
even clutter then we got immense value
from the postal service once upon a time
and now i would say it gets more in the
way than than well than creating value
in our lives really if you go to the
minimalists.com
day 15 there are a few links there for
you one is to the direct marketing
association they offer free online only
service at dmacc.org
that stops catalogs and junk mail
deliveries and so if you go there dma
choice.org it will eliminate 90 plus
percent of your
well of your excess junk mail that is
coming into your home and that's the
best way to eliminate paper clutter by
the way is to stop it from coming in in
the first place there's another app that
i use i think it costs a dollar to a
month not a sponsor but it's called
paper karma
and paper karma allows me to if i do end
up getting a junk mail credit card
offers etc in the mail i will just take
a photo of it with my with that app and
it will automatically unsubscribe me
it's like doing the email unsubscribe
button but through an app for your
physical mail so we'll put a link to
to paper karma the app as well if you
head on over to direct marketing
association dmacc.org you'll probably
also find
optoutprescreen.com emily i hope that
helps you out i'd love to see you later
this month in seattle it's the love
people use things tour i'm going to send
you a couple tickets if anyone else is
interested the minimalists.com
slash tour we're coming to a city near
you 20 cities in total we'll be in
vancouver and seattle and san francisco
and los angeles and toronto and columbus
and chicago and minneapolis and several
other cities or you can find all 20
events
over on patreon now it is time for our
lightning round this is where we answer
your questions from social media you can
text your questions to 937-202-4654
those texts literally go to ryan's and
my phone
and so you can text ryan today and say
hey get well soon we hope to see you on
the next episode but during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
and our guests we typically answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com
it looks like rachel has a question for
us i have a ton of paper clutter i want
to go through but it would take so much
time where do i begin to tackle such a
huge time commitment you know i think
this is
the biggest reason people
they don't um they don't address the
paper clutter at all or any clutter if
the average american home has 300 000
items in it or maybe 300 000 pieces of
paper and all those file cabinets and
boxes and bins and oh where do i even
start well you start where we all start
we start with a question
how might your life be better with less
clutter
and by answering that question by the
way that's my pithy answer for today but
by answering that question
you're able to identify the purpose of
simplifying the purpose of the
decluttering the paper clutter so how
might your life be better with less
paper clutter is an appropriate question
i think that applies to all the other
areas in our lives on the maximal
episode this week we're going to talk
about career clutter and emotional
clutter and calendar clutter and
organizational clutter isn't it crazy to
be like we go to these stores to buy a
bunch of organizing tools and boxes and
bins and label makers
it creates new clutter to address our
current clutter it's pretty quixotic to
think that more tools more stuff is
going to fix my problem with stuff
and so yes it really starts with that
question well why does it start with
that question
rachel if you don't understand why
this is such a problem for you you're
not going to experience enough pain in
order to remove that excess from your
life but if you really understand why
you'll understand what is all this
clutter getting in the way of where is
it taking up space it's not just taking
up space in your home
it's taking up space
all throughout your life in your head
and your heart
it's weighing you down psychologically
if you let it go
you also let go
of that weight
you know we've got a bunch more to talk
about in fact i have two added values
for you today during our added value
segment but first right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist since it's the
new year
you might be looking for some resources
so if you head on over to
theminimalists.com
slash resources or you can just go to
the minimalists.com click resources at
the top we have a bunch of free
resources over there for you not only do
we have our simple sunday newsletter
with more than 600 essays or you can get
our podcast show notes in your inbox for
free we have our minimalist book 16
rules for living with less that you can
download right there
also the 30-day minimalism game a free
calendar you can download seven
different minimalist wallpapers for your
phone or your computer we have
minimalist home tours we have our values
worksheet this is the time of year where
my wife and i we sit down and we go over
our values our foundational values have
those changed probably not structural
values have those changed
they might they might shift around a bit
sometimes values change categories
something that was
more valuable to us a decade ago may be
less valuable to us now it may not even
be a value at all have our surface
values change yeah those change all the
time the things that we find interesting
or fun to do those surface values they
tend to change quite a bit and so why do
we go over that together well it's
because my wife and i we want to better
understand each other because the better
we understand each other the better we
communicate the better we're able to
love so you can download our free values
worksheet over there as well we've got
several other resources i have a free
ebook called 11 ways to write better we
have another free ebook over there
called financial freedom
it talks about
five steps five difficult steps toward
financial freedom you can find all of
that over at theminimalists.com
resources those are all free resources
that you can download today we've got so
much more to talk about but first what
do you got for us here are some
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners hello this is bryce from
delaware beach florida i wanted to share
a tip that i came up with to live a more
balanced and intentional life
what i did was i have a planner that
instead of
going by the hour it goes by the
different realms of health
and it made this really cool acronym
that's easy to remember and easy to
apply
and that's special
every day is special and every day is an
opportunity to grow
spiritually physically emotionally
communally intellectually
adaptively and lucratively
hey guys this is tracy from denver
colorado i'm calling to say thank you
because
in early 2017 i listened to your podcast
on finances and budgeting
and you kept talking about dave ramsey
and i
i started going into that rabbit hole
listening to his podcast
and
because of that and the knowledge that
you guys share i'm sitting here tonight
with this being the last night i ever
have debt i make my final payment
tomorrow and i will be debt-free for the
first time in 23 years
i've been busting my butt at this for
uh one year and
363 days so i am extremely excited to
celebrate this milestone tomorrow and i
thank you guys because
prior to listening to those podcasts i
was just looking for a way to figure out
how to manage my finances better and it
felt so difficult and complicated and
you guys made it so easy and shared
information and it has changed my life
all right y'all before we get to our
double added value segment this week
let's read a quick testimonial from one
of our patreon supporters this one's
from chance hollingsworth that is not a
made up name that's an actual
patreon supporter shout out chance he
says i recently took the plunge here on
patreon for the private podcast and i'm
so grateful i did the first episode i
listened to was the recent ken coleman
conversation and i cannot express just
how timely that discussion was for me
i've been wrestling with some career
choices recently and the wisdom in that
episode really hit home in fact i'm not
one to re-listen to a podcast episode on
repeat until that one in a word thanks
for your message your work and for
helping this admitted collector begin
the process of simplifying his life with
less
wow chance thank you so much shout out
to our patreon supporters thank you for
keeping this podcast 100
advertisement free for added value this
week
the 80s are back ladies and gentlemen i
feel like they've kind of been back all
year but like it's sort of this
all last year i should say there's sort
of this crescendo right now and so two
of my favorite albums of 2021 i'm going
to talk about today
and it's weird because they're both they
both sound like 80s music but they are
both radically different albums so
torrey lanes has a new album out it's
called alone at prom which is like an
80s title
even the opening track to that is called
enchanted waterfall so jordan if folks
are watching the youtube video i think
if i point right here and say hey if you
click on this thing right up here you
can actually check out the video for
that i don't know if there's a music
video if not there'll be a audio video
there
and so tory lanez it
strikes me as sort of like this r b soul
80s music it has that 80s pop feel but
with a little bit of r b and soul
infused into it and then we have
my second added value this week sam
outlaw he has a new album now called
popular mechanics and
it's like americana pop alt country
music but both of these albums sound
strangely similar
and the opening track to that is one of
my favorite songs of 2021.
that song's called here on a mission so
if you're watching on youtube again you
can click up here or if you're listening
to the audio version of the podcast you
can just check the show notes for links
to both of those albums tory lanez alone
at prom and sam outlaw popular mechanics
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like how do you deal
with calendar clutter relationship
clutter mental clutter and other types
of non-material clutter is it possible
to buy nothing
for an entire year
can minimalism actually make you happier
plus a million more questions for the
minimalists and our team here and if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tick tock instagram facebook and twitter
at the minimalists if you want our
podcast show notes in your inbox sign up
for our email list at
theminimalistics.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburn reminding you to
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it